martin biron paul journet michel ces
objets bonsoir quelle histoire
monsieur camara qui est menée chez lui
un homme libre qui a été libéré mais il
ya une épée de damoclès
je vous fais entendre la mairesse
qu'elle est très claire alors judiciaire
rien sur la personne qu'on s'excuse
qu'on le dise haut et fort et tout de
suite après écoute et bien deux chefs de
police et est innocent et il faut le
répéter haut et fort ce que l'on
souhaite c'est qu'il y ait une enquête
une enquête qui va être neutre et qui va
se faire rapidement maintenant il faut
pas attendre parce que ce qui s'est
passé est grave
comprenons que la situation est
exceptionnelle des conséquences sont
regrettables
nous sommes en pensée avec la famille de
monsieur camara c'est très regrettable
ce qui se passe pour le moment monsieur
camara il est libre et de la mer
toujours un témoin important
et comme cydia tantôt au moment opportun
s'il est évident doit s'excuser
on s'exposera au moment les sports on
aura tous les éléments nécessaires pour
le faire a continué le chien de police
car en dia et eu des prélèvements qui
ont été faits pour natal et avec
impatience les résultats lui dans sa
tête n'est pas du tout prêts pour
l'instant à disculper camara michels et
vos réactions je suis quand vous faites
un détour pour laisser l'impression
justement que donc je suis maman est pas
sorti de l'auberge qu'il y en ait encore
des raisons de croire que la police pour
tromper et que donc éventuellement il
pourrait y avoir des accusations de
chant portées contre lui il n'a pas dit
conten il y trop habile pour ça mais
l'impression est un casse alors un
moment donné d'abord on a pas on
apprenait être un peu plus tôt par m
verrez votre invité que chez canal ans
et libre de toute accusation pour un an
d'abord c'est sa première des choses que
deuxièmement il ya probablement une
autre voiture à chevaux pourquoi je sais
qu'avant utiliser ces sous-entendus là
mais il est très clair qu'il les a
utilisés et je sais pas si c'est pour
parce qu'il prend contact ce que la
mairesse audi tous les pots cassés
de toute évidence là il ya quelque chose
qui ne marche pas dassin en même temps
paul me faire l'avocat du terme et en
même temps peut-être qu'à des éléments
qui le pousse à être très prudents avant
de disculper monsieur camara à cette
étape ci on ne peut que spéculer on ne
sait pas s'il a des informations que
nous on a pas
mais moi n'ayant pas ces éléments
l'autre ce que je prenne noté c'est la
grande différence entre le message d'une
femme où la mairesse 10h un problème il
ya quelqu'un qui a commis une erreur
parce que c'est le spm le dpcp laideur
dans quelle mesure elle ne sait pas mais
chose certaine il ya eu une big ya
quelqu'un qui avaient été lésés et il
faut absolument une enquête et
rapidement alors que le mot qui revenait
dans la bouche du chef car l'intérieur
rigueur rigueur et disaient nos
enquêteurs on vient à se rapprocher
ils ont bien fait leur travail dont il
faudra voir les résultats de la tête
mais moins juste un hymne à l'idée que
j'ai c'est imaginez s'il y avait plus de
caméras si on était à une époque avant
la technologie qu'est ce qui serait
advenu de cet homme et si on avait les
caméras corporelles sur le policier je
ne sais pas s'il aurait permis de capter
le suspect dans ce cas particulier mais
peut-être et c'est un argument plus pour
ceux qui veulent des caméras corporels
sur les policiers la caméra comparé elle
n'aurait pas capté parce qu'ils étaient
de dôme et la caméra voiture parce que
il ya une option de le mettre les
américains mettent sur la voiture savard
et capter mais martin qu'en pensez-vous
c'est ce que paul soulignent les deux
branches sont tombées quand j'entends du
chef de police dans la mesure où comme
la mairesse avait été très loin je me
disais que c'était quand même parler il
y avait pas du tout lui continue à dire
n'allez pas si vite ce qui dit il ya
deux choses qui me vient en tête sur
cette histoire là d'abord quand j'écoute
le chef caron je me dis c'est pas demain
la veille qu'on va savoir exactement ce
qui s'est passé en matière d' enquête
ça touche la police le spvm ça touche
aussi le dpcp comment l'anc est c'est
fait comment ils ont communiqué ensemble
c'est un milieu extrêmement opaque on le
sait et ça va être difficile pour un
enquêteur externe de faire la lumière de
corroborer tous ces faits là et on a un
gouvernement
quand même peu expérimentés dans le
domaine est assez frileux qui crée
l'interférence alors ça va être assez
difficile de savoir à court terme ce qui
s'est passé mais l'autre chose qui me
sont aux yeux et là je reviens aux
années où je couvrais la commission
denquête poitras sur les méthodes
enquête de la sûreté du québec et qui
avait recommandé que dans des coques
comme celui-là on fasse à faire un tiers
pour faire les enquêtes
écoutez c'est un casier mais police eut
bel le sait un policier du spvm qui est
victime d'une tentative de meurtre alors
et la charge émotive chez les collègues
elle est importante
alors il faut voir clair éviter en fait
la vision du tunnel et essayer d'être
sûrs et est en fait le chef de police
ce sont des enquêteurs les plus
expérimentés qui doivent travailler sur
ce type d' enquête là alors monsieur
caron le chef car on s'est dit ouvert à
un observateur extérieur mais pourquoi
ça n'a pas été le cas
d'emblée peut-être qu'on aurait éviter
d'arrêter
monsieur camara trouvé ça c'est
intéressant vous le soulignez martin
parce qu'à la toute fin du pour une
presse plus car on dit si vous insistez
envoyer un observateur effectivement
puis on va en vol on va là soir dans un
coin le jeu je caricature évidemment
mais mais sinon il était très ferme
lundi l'inquiétait pas finie mesdames et
messieurs c'est ça qui est venu dire on
va entendre d'abord je vous montrais un
tweet de madame guilbaud et qui elle il
faut examiner tout cela qui est en
réponse à la mairesse les circonstances
ayant conduit à la mise en accusation de
monsieur monsieur farrar camarades
doivent être examinés nous travaillons
avec la ville de montréal sur la formule
la plus optimale tout en respectant
l'enquète gspm qui est toujours en cours
donc là on va essayer tout veut un peu
la chèvre et le chou dans la mesure où
on risque d'envoyer martine loock 30
second jour donne la parole quelqu'un du
berry peut-être ou nommer quelqu'un mais
il est probablement mélo ou à peu près
tout le monde a raison c'est que l'anc
est là sur la tentative de meurtre elle
n'est pas terminée alors il ya des
comètes des élus
mende qui peuvent pas sortir le c'est à
dire que peut-être que quelqu'un dans
les prochaines heures
prochains jours sera accusé de cette
tentative de meurtre là alors il ya
quand même des informations qui doivent
les cadres doivent rester quand même
assez proche au prato mois puis je
reviens ce que paul et michel g ce que
je comprends pas c'est que si la police
l'a vise 1,3 un autre suspect qui
courent toujours en passant comment se
fait-il que le chef ne pas laisser aller
la pression sur camarades parce que lui
pour convaincu encore deux seuls paul
est ce que vous voulez mais chez vous
comprenez mon jeu la main et concilier
les versions là mais ça ça se négocie
pas jeudi la chef cas voire carrément
voulu dire il ya encore un nuage sur la
personne de monsieur camara
ce n'est pas réglé cette affaire lors
pour ce pauvre % quant à lui on
s'excusera si un jour on a accès que je
puisse aimer c'est pas mal ça va se
faire qu'est ce que vous voulez
quelqu'un qu'on conclut de sa hotte qu'
il est toujours dans la mire des
policiers
j'espère qu'il a de bonnes raisons
d'affirmer ça parce que sinon ça serait
exceptionnellement injuste pour un seul
camara est quand même un juge qui l'a
exonéré faut pas oublier ça monsieur
caron d'une suspension qui du reste est
effectivement en fait le juge a dit oui
arrêt des procédures on axait mais vous
avez un an pour aller compléter cette
enquête le concernant monsieur camara
parce qu'ensuite c'est terminé on peut
pas accuser deux fois deux mêmes
personnes du même crime
on va attendre monsieur jolie barrette
qui lui a défendu lundi le dpcp et
quelques membres de l'opposition
comprendre que le dos aussi présentement
fait des fait l'objet d'une enquête
avec le spvm dès le moment dès le moment
monsieur le président où il ya un doute
ou des informations ont été communiquées
au directeur des poursuites criminelles
et pénales
il y a eu
des accusations je me dis c'est
épouvantable il faut absolument aller au
fond de fond des choses
la seule chose à faire présentement
c'est d'aller au fond des choses qui est
une enquête puis qu'on puisse savoir ce
qui s'est réellement passé en matière de
profilage racial cpo québec soldat qu'il
l'a inventé plusieurs intervenants
plusieurs recherches la commission des
droits de la personne
bref on le sait que ça existe est ce que
c'est le cas présentement belle la
question est sur toutes les lèvres et
l'effort juste sur la question du
profilage racial monsieur caron était
vendu absolument pour rien rien à voir
un tour de table là dessus martin
la question se pose et je pense que dans
une enquête la question devrait se poser
est ce que c'est la dominante que je
sais pas mais la question se pose très
certainement paul eymond la
compréhension du profilage racial cd
intervention est justifiée d'un policier
auprès d'une personne parce
qu'inconsciemment à cause de la couleur
de sa peau on se dit qu'il faudrait
intervenir auprès d'elle ça me semble
être un code différents sauf que et sans
parler de cette cause spécifiquement ont
présenté de façon générale dans les
dernières décennies si comme dans
d'autres pays
il ya eu un billet raciale on demande
d'identifier des témoins qui ont fait en
sorte des personnes de couleur ont été
accusé pour des crimes qu'ils n'avaient
pas commis
mais le biais raciale profilage racial
pour ça que c'est tout à fait le même
concert
je le suis je veux savoir je cherche je
peux vous dire c'est du profilage racial
est une composante
c'est clair et d'autre part martin
permettre de vision tunnel cette affaire
c'est ça le problème aussi c'est qu'à un
moment donné c'est un policier qui était
la victime
ça remue les policiers s'éteindre c'est
un des leurs qui ont été victimes ne
veulent régler sa dette
et là il y avait quelqu'un gayda
mauvaise place au mauvais moment
en plus de show oui elle une question
raciale da alors
le côté des deux autres est bon il nous
reste il nous reste une minute trente de
jeu je vous pose deux questions presque
oui ou non mais est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet de ce que vous entendez sur la
livraison des vaccins un premier réponse
et de à ce que le sucre dont une part de
responsabilité rapidement martin c'est
les attentes étaient très élevées le
prix politique risque d'être énorme pour
monsieur trudeau il semble se débattre
comme un petit chien dans l'eau bénite
paul paul oui je suis inquiet et je
pense que monsieur trudeau il est encore
plus parce que sa capacité de retourner
en campagne électorale et d'être élues
en départ
sa stratégie c'est de s'en remettre aux
recommandations du comité vaccin mais on
peut se demander si le temps qu'on a
pris pour négocier avec la chine et
aussi sur les garanties qu'on a obtenu
quant aux délais de livraison par
l'achat mais le délai de livraison at il
tout fait en son possible on dise les
résultats en ce moment sont pas en sa
faveur
michel / g monsieur trudeau ont promis
très haut et il risque de livrer très
parce qu'il inverse ce qu'on doit faire
en politique ce lundi objectivement le
canada est dans la même situation qu'à
peu près tous les pays du golfe qui ne
produisent pas de vaccin on est seul
pays du g7 qu'en conduite autre exemple
mais on a tout le monde s est joué du
coude droit voire du vaccin c'est
pourquoi
merci beaucoup de voix discipline merci
désolé vous avoir donné supporter sur un
gros sujets comme la vaccination va y
revenir évidemment au revoir bonne
soirée pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit